قبل أن أغادر ، سأعود إلى Andrews
لبطولة Alfred Dunhill Lynx
للحاق بشخص آخر
لديه شغف بلعبة
التسخين المتداول ، وهو نجم البوب ​​الأيرلندي الذي
صعد إلى الشهرة في التسعينيات مع مجموعة
أوزون البوب ​​التي سيواصلها  للاستمتاع
بمهنة فردية رائعة في بيع عشرات الملايين من
التسجيلات مع أغاني مثل Life as a
rollaster coaster
[Music
] وعندما لا تقول شيئًا على الإطلاق
عندما تقول لا شيء على الإطلاق ، كان كيتنغ
لاعب غولف متعطشًا طوال حياته
المهنية وهو لاعب عادي  في هذا الحدث ،
أخبرنا ما الذي تعتقد أن لعبة
الجولف أعطتك لعبة الجولف هي كرة القدم الخاصة بي إذا كان بإمكاني فعل
أي شيء آخر في حياتي
التي تعرفها كوظيفة ، فسيكون أن
أكون لاعب غولف محترف.
مشاهدته ، أحب
اللعب ، من الواضح
أنه يمنحني الحرية ،
فهو يمنحني راحة البال ،
ويعطيني معرفة ما يجب التركيز عليه
بعيدًا عن الأشياء الأخرى التي أعتقد أنها من أجل
صحتك العقلية ، شيء مثل الجولف هو
شيء رائع وأنت تعلم أنني سأفعل ذلك.  قل
ذلك ل k  هويات وأصدقاء دائمًا
والذين كانوا أبطالك في لعبة الجولف ، حسنًا ،
غاري بلاير هو بطلي في لعبة الجولف ، ما زال حتى
اليوم يكبر ،
لكنني الآن محظوظ بما يكفي للعب
معه للعمل معه ،
إنه أسطورة إنه ألطف  رجل في
العالم
هو مثل كل آبائنا الذين تعلمون
أنه مجرد شخص مميز جدًا
ولم يكن جيدًا ، لقد كان
لاعب غولف رائعًا من الواضح أنه لا يزال
لاعب غولف رائعًا ورجلًا رائعًا
كيف تقارن لعب
الجولف
أشعر بالراحة في التحكم بالآلاف من الدولارات مقابل لعب عرض أمام آلاف الدولارات في عالمين مختلفين أشعر
بالراحة في ما
يغني به ميكروفون على يدي ويؤدي
الوقوف على الغابة هنا حتى في
جولة تدريب اليوم كنت أقوم بالهلع
بعد الأول  عندما يكون لديك تدقيق
مثل حشد من الأشخاص الذين يتابعون
المسبار الذي تلعب معه ، فهو
أكثر تجربة محطمة للأعصاب ، فلا يوجد
شيء يقترب من الأعصاب التي
تتحدث عن هذه الدورات الثلاث.
أي منها هو المفضل لديك جيدًا ، أعتقد أن
سانت أندروز خاصة بشكل لا يصدق ،
أعني أن كينغز بارنز هو أجمل
ما يميز سانت أندروز
،
إنه مجرد مكان رائع مشهد
ملعب
الجولف أو التاريخ هناك الكثير الذي
تعرفه وراءه  هذا المكان وبالنسبة لي ،
فإن الحصول على فرصة للعب هو
امتياز حقيقي